good morning everybody welcome to roses
and Rose a live here on ET I am with
just an absolute icon the bachelor
nation Beckett Tilly thank you for being
here we are going to talk last night's
episode of Becca ku friends season of
The Bachelorette and of course we want
to know what you guys thinks to leave
your comments and your questions and
anything that you also just want to ask
Becca about herself because we're gonna
catch up with her to let us know and
we'll get them here on our et iPad I
want to dive into last night's episode
but first I just kind of want to get
your read Becca Tilly on this season
we're at a midpoint you're an alum how
are you feeling about the season so far
well I feel thank you for having me Dana
called me an icon a cure I mean but I
almost feel like my seasons were ages
ago like that feels so like you include
the bachelor at Bachelor Winter Games
bachelor in paradise and I'm like oh
it's been a long time since I've been on
the show but I don't know watching it
and seeing like the drama and like even
the emotions that Chris felt last night
that frustrating feeling of like I'm not
getting enough attention it takes you
back to like a dark place doesn't it
PTSD like some of those feelings were so
I you know you you're like okay he
obviously could have handled it much
better but I do remember having that
feeling of being like Oh Ben's like
clearly into some of the other girls
like should I just pack my bags and go
home like you know I'm used to having
the attention on me so it's funny
watching it and sometimes I forget and
want to be like get it together like
you're one of like you knew going on the
show yeah other people that's the thing
right as you do and I'm wavering because
like you said we've gotten a lot of
seasons of bachelor nation shows lately
Nick vile was here and he was like it
wasn't that long ago since my season but
I don't know baby
yeah because winter games and paradise
and a lot of you know drama as we love
has happen
but you do watch these guys and think I
mean even late last night I think chris
said he wanted another one on
and Lincoln said well you're not gonna
get that and Chris said what historical
data do you have to back that up and I
said twenty five seasons of the show
be more I mean with Bachelor about show
there's more yeah you're not gonna get
another one and one and don't they know
how many guys are gonna be there and
don't they so I don't know but I guess
you just get real caught up in it well I
got two one-on-ones in a row so I asked
what I had once I have my one-on-one on
Christmas season I had one every mine
was really late but every week after
that I had a 101 mm-hmm
so Chris wasn't that far off we talked
to him at all how is he Oh crystals no I
haven't I've you know we'll exchange
like a text here and there like totally
ran him out of the blue but no I haven't
talked to him he's coming back I've seen
he's back on Instagram back I know I'll
see him like like my photos I feel like
he's just a guy who everybody in the
world does lovely I know
so speaking of one-on-ones okay let's
dive into the episode and first I want
to talk about Jason's one on one which I
considered a very weird date it was at
some kind of I don't even know what this
was an Edgar Allan Poe the moment I'm
like what is this and I'm gonna call the
show out a little bit here because as
much as I love this show the dates all
episode long on last night's episode
were very mediocre to me I was just
thinking I'm starting to wonder because
I remember on on well been season I had
the one-on-one where we married people
in Vegas which is fun and different but
on Christmas season there were a few
times on my one-on-one where we were
just like walking around and would like
going to a store or something I'm like
where's the helicopter yeah well it's
hard cuz I think you think you want to
have grounded moments that feel real
totally cause people talk about The
Bachelor bubble but at the same time I'm
watching a TV show I want to see
something glamorous and something
escapist that you can't have in real or
that's like unrealistic in real life
look at the t-one right so we went from
whatever that was to then
Jason's friends showing up so Jason's
friends are brought in and I didn't
really understand this we'd flown
Jason's friends to Richmond for it I
guess to have happy hour we couldn't
read the whole bar oh so we said hi to
them I
at their names we didn't really have
much conversation it was cute how happy
he was to see them but I I didn't
understand this why are we flying
Jason's friends to Richmond there was a
lot I Jason's date was strange
however mm-hmm I loved it I like Jason
yes I'm with you on this
like he quickly went up to my top three
for her hmm tell me why I don't know
there was just their chemistry he's very
easy to watch and like even talking like
a lot of times on those dates they got
in it is hard because you're kind of
like all of a sudden you're talking
about these really deep things that you
only talk about yeah and he seems very
comfortable and natural wears a lot of
time you're like well they're really
forcing this conversation about their
last relationship that they clearly
don't want to talk about and he talked
about something so personal and it still
felt like I didn't feel uncomfortable
watching it mm-hm you know I agree he
feels very grounded to me and I like
that he's funny he makes like he
actually makes me laugh how do you feel
about his hair I don't love the hair I'm
hoping that there's a revamp somewhere
yeah I've noticed on Instagram he's gone
a little less gel really yes everyone
has a moment after they get off the show
or they like they're like see like all
it takes is America watching and
pointing out your like the things they
don't like about to you for you to go oh
did you like it change up your glam or
anything after seeing yourself in - yeah
yeah I mean well I mean you just kind of
go through where you're like you're
critiquing yourself every week and yeah
and then everyone else is critiquing you
and you're like oh I could change this
or that but yeah I really I really like
him and I feel like they have a very
easy chemistry and he looks like a good
kisser and she has said he is we've
really gotten some zoom zoom in on yeah
zooming in on that um comments coming in
Monica says on Facebook okay because she
wants to know right now who do you think
will be the last two men standing Monica
is guessing Colton and Garrett I'm
having a hard time with Colton yeah just
really threw me off and so everything
sometimes when he's speaking him like
you know I just kind of roll my eyes but
she's really into him I think she's
really attract I think
very cute I think Garret for sure and
I'm leaning towards Garrett and Blake or
Garrett and Jason mm-hmm yeah I'm liking
almost guys wills this kind of he's
really chill I like the guys who take a
step back and they don't get caught up
in it and he's funny too
Vicki on facebook says Becca would you
ever go on the shows again bachelor
bachelorette bachelor in paradise
Bachelor winter games are so many things
um I don't think I would do paradise or
Bachelor the only thing it would even
maybe consider would be Bachelorette and
that would be like a you know they
already of the Becca there is Becca I
know and there were so many tweets that
night and I remember you kind of played
it off because Becca and it would have
been a great surprise really yes because
he liked Whitney me Nick bachelor that I
think a lot of people were surprised
like who we just you know they didn't
follow the formula now that Becca kufran
isn't great and I think we all were
Ronnie yeah I like a surprise move you
know so you would do Bachelorette I
talked about during the so were you
what's the dating situation right now
I'm just dating nothing serious it's
it's interesting because I feel like my
last relationship was very you know I
just put it all out there I talked about
I posted about it and I'm like you know
I know that's really all people care
about my life that's what I feel like
sometimes it's like well cuz that's they
followed my they followed me because
they we're watching me in a relationship
but sometimes I'm like maybe I need to
take a step back and hold some things
like to myself until I until I feel like
okay it's comfortable enough to talk
about so it kind of makes you think I'm
not gonna go on social media with the
relationship immediately yeah okay or
until I yeah until it feels like I don't
want to like put it out there if it's
not something that I feel like okay I
can this is something people should get
invested in and this is this person is
gonna be my life you know cuz did you
get like backlash after the breakup is
that why not backlash I just feel like
people it almost felt like I was
disappointing people which it's like oh
this is my life and like I should feel
disappointed in the fact that it didn't
work out on my own but not that I'm
letting other people down know their
your emotions yeah what about the way
that you date now like
Nik vial again was here and he was I was
surprised he's like I'm not on the apps
I don't do the apps but I feel like
everybody does and it seems so necessary
like how do you meet people now I think
just through friends just maybe I mean
the thing with the the thing is that you
can go out somewhere and meet people and
everyone's kind of in the same boat of
you talk to people I talk to so many
girls and guys and they're like I don't
want to be on the apps but it's like how
do you meet people everyone's in the
same boat yeah I don't really know it's
just like through friends or just yeah
randomly would you date someone in the
bachelor nation alumni world again I
mean I never say never but if it
happened it happened but I do remember
my mom being like May really date
someone outside well the world just
keeps getting bigger I don't know
everybody maybe in it at some point
speaking of all the guys I want to now
move into the debate date so we're in
Richmond Virginia and we're doing this
date that's all about a debate with the
guys and I did not love this just
because things got so petty so quickly
Beca looked great the guys looked great
in their suits but I just felt like the
back and forth got so immature what was
your reaction the whole time in Virginia
with between Lincoln and Chris on the
couch I determined my captions on
because I couldn't they were like
mumbling fighting yeah it was a strange
that was a strange exchange yeah it was
like that was the thing is I felt I
don't even know why these guys don't
like each other I don't really know what
they're fighting about it didn't feel
grounded in anything - but I was also
like why won't one of them just stand up
and walk away like he's like don't touch
me okay like we're really I don't know
is that them
getting caught up in the world yeah it
was like Lincoln and Chris just fighting
with each other again not even sure what
they were fighting about body shaming
got brought up at one point cuz I guess
we hadn't really known this before but I
guess had weighed more before and he
said Lincoln was being mean to him about
that I also wanted to get your take is
obviously we now know what has come out
about Lincoln that he was arrested and
convicted of indecent assault on a woman
so it's very strange to me to watch this
back now I don't know if they could have
edited him out
the entire show that would have been
hard but it's weird to watch him have
these interactions knowing what we now
know I have noticed they don't show much
there's not a lot of interaction of him
with Becca like in my head I don't like
first I felt like all we saw was Lincoln
and I could just hear I would like go to
sleep and I could hear him talking like
his accent yeah and I feel like they've
kind of like limited how much they're
showing mm-hmm do you think like maybe
went back and made because I feel like
they did they have removed his head shot
from the website so
oh yeah that's official yeah it makes me
think I'll be interested to see if we
see him at mental all because remember
with Lee Garrett there were the issues
with his son Rachel season and that was
obviously he was his tweets were seen as
racist but it's a whole other level when
you've actually been kind of a crime
yeah I mean I'll be I'll be surprised I
mean the only way they would do it is
for the drama aspect of it but it's
almost like what's worth you know your
reputation bringing bringing out I know
it's a tough call and then the drama
continued with Chris and I have to say
it felt like you know there have been a
lot of there been a couple fights this
season with both Jordan and Dave and
then it's Lincoln and Chris I'm like not
on anybody's side like I don't agree
with anyone in these things you know
what I mean usually you're raptor
rooting for one guy but then we have
this moment with Becca and Chris where
Chris goes to see Becca and he's kind of
trying to redeem himself and she's
ultimately going to send him home and
we're gonna play a little bit of sound
from that in just a minute but what did
you think of Chris and what he was
saying I felt like his his anger was
unjustified yeah yeah it's almost like
he got so far in his head like the no
shot of him writing the one I was
watching but yeah it just felt so
intense and I'm like I remember that
feeling of feeling like Oh like why am I
not getting attention but there's a
moment where you kind of have to process
like I'm on the show I'm not the only
person here right and like really bring
yourself back down to earth and put
yourself like in this situation and yeah
did not do that no I mean he's a thirty
year old man and so I want to play that
sound if we can of where he walks out so
Becca's gonna walk Chris out he says he
doesn't want to be walked out and we
have a little clip of that moment I'm
gonna say I'm gonna walk you out because
you deserve I don't think you need
anything but I'm gonna give you that
respect like I was like here's the thing
I know this is a reality show but when
the dialogue is at that level I'm like
we gotta I don't want to be walked out I
don't want he's like I don't need to be
walked down to like I know you don't
need to right I mean the whole thing
just felt like again I am I didn't
believe that he really has these
feelings for Becca and I didn't feel
like she was into him at that oh yeah
that's just no yeah I mean if a guy came
to my room oh saying but just like
acting the way he acted on the group
dates and everything his pal D he wasn't
attractive no and I wanted to ask you
you and I were talking a little bit
about this before we started here but
this is just my sense of things I do
feel like the past couple of seasons you
know people have talked about like how
the show gives you Instagram Fame and
your social media famous elongated from
being on the show which is great yeah
but I do feel that some of these guys I
think castings gotten harder for them
because some of the contestants are just
going on from now more than ever do you
get that sense especially meeting people
and spending time with them after
they've been on the show now yeah I mean
I I think meeting people it is different
because you meet someone and they're
like much more yeah I've been watching
an edited show of they're like the
version of them but it I was saying
earlier like I do feel like Ben's season
was kind right after that was when the
social media I don't know if I was just
oblivious to it before but that was when
for me it felt like a Bennigan's and
that launched that instable afterwards
like I've never talked about like no one
was ever talking about Encino that
wasn't something the girls talked about
like how many followers or anything like
that and then after Ben's season which I
went back to my old job and everything
so my life was very normal I
just had a bunch of followers following
my normal life at that point yeah you
know and without any business aspect of
it and so I think after that season was
when Instagram kind of took off and of
course there's that like appealed for
people now they're like wait I can
travel the world and good endure like
brands and like sponsored posts and so
it does make it hard to watch because
I'm wondering the same thing yeah is
there anything that they can do I mean
kind of knowing that world is there
anything you would see and knowing the
way that the show's cast like a change
that could be made a different approach
what do you think I don't know I mean I
I don't know how you weed out like who's
there and the thing is I mean I went on
the show I was just like why not like
what an experience out of you know all
the people who have been nominated and
like gone to castings they called me so
why you know my head was like why not
but I had no idea that my life would be
what it is now yeah so you do get the
sense that people are going on like more
for the Instagram more for the followers
now than in the past yeah I mean I think
it's the same as like going on a reality
show before the social media thing it
was like oh I'm gonna be on TV like I'll
have my 15 minutes of fame or whatever
it's similar I mean it's the same
mindset it's just you can get it's all
right there everyone's fingertips now
yeah well some people have even said
like you know because there was also
this Garrett Instagram scam I think some
people have said it should the show just
acknowledge this more like should the
lead have access to a phone to like scan
people on social yeah then by the way
when he was here not long ago and he
told me that he was in a hotel room
waiting to go on Lauren bushnell's
hometown and the hotel room had an iPad
in it and so he used the iPad and had
the internet for the first time and he
looked up Lauren and Jojo and everybody
before his like final three so he did it
he got on the inner thank you baby Ben I
mean does that happen more than we think
do yeah I mean I had I actually brought
a phone on my second season Bagatelle I
love this so how did you get that phone
in there do they not check your also it
wasn't my I gave them my phone I had
like like um cell service and everything
they gave him that one but I had
basically as like an iTouch I had music
on it and if I had Wi-Fi and was able to
the Wi-Fi password I would just like
just check it with my family you know I
was pretty I was like mild with it cuz I
was terrified of getting caught I think
a lot of people get caught but I was
pretty like you know yeah so a lot of
people do try to sneak the phones oh oh
I think it's happened quite a few times
where someone's tried and it's like you
have to be really stealth and like you
can't just have it out and use it I've
used it for emergencies where I felt
like oh you're having a breakdown so do
people do you see people like a producer
rocks over there like come here
I've never seen anyone like there's
compass and confiscated but I have heard
stories about it happening were there
yeah they're just kind of like the
handlers or the producers come on well
what do you think is there anything the
show should do to like change revamp in
terms of kind of modern I mean because
the thing is on the one hand we love the
show for the formula right on the other
hand it's been on for a long time right
so I don't know anything when you're
watching do you want to change anything
or adjust um I don't know I'm always I'm
kind of the type who's like if you have
a good thing that's working like like if
it's not broke don't fix it
but I'm sure there's there's things that
they could do to make it just a little
more I don't know what it is because I
think there's something to be said
because we're like in that situation
you're so far removed from the world and
what's going on on social media that
it's kind of a nice break and you do
that's how they get the emotions and the
drama so like to give people access to
that it would almost be taking away from
what they're able to get out of yeah
pros and cons mm-hmm so Abby wants to
know do you like Blake I like Blake what
are your thoughts oh I know I took a
minute I liked Blake I think he's he
seems like so kind and genuine and they
have like a very intense connection I
feel like when they're together they're
just like I really like him I really
like her for me there's something I'm
just not like super into okay what is it
it's almost like I almost feel like he's
he's younger right he seems younger and
I don't know it's it's not anything like
bad or anything it might just be that I
don't have that connection with him
yeah from the TV screen okay she's not
connecting and hey it's about
connections and gut feelings and Breanna
from YouTube is saying now that we know
about Lincoln's past do you think
Chris's remarks about him being
aggressive like carry more importance I
mean I just felt like watching Chris and
Lincoln they both in those moments
seemed over-the-top I don't know Chris
himself was not really blowing me away
with his handling yeah but okay so I
want to get into because people are also
asking me and he wants to know who we
think she'll take on hometown dates so
let's show a little bit as we're talking
here of the promo for next week we have
this promo for next week where we are
heading to the Bahamas we're finally
getting some glam lakes in that palm
tree t-shirt prints that he's wearing
we've got Leo wills Garrett Blake and
Colton here still of course do three
people go to hometowns right or is it
four Wow four I'm okay good we watched
the show three four no we have our four
that go to hometowns in our final three
so hometowns I'm gonna say it's feeling
like Jason Garrett Blake and Will's to
me I don't know I think Leo Leo I felt
like she had this great one-on-one date
with him last night but it was so late
wait I thought she was gonna send him
home on the day I was surprised yeah
like I didn't feel like she was super
into him well right and then she said we
feel a spark there but I'm like it's too
late for a spark we got a B because they
put me on fire four or five again where
am i this morning yeah we're a little
summer I'm just trying to think like my
one-on-one date with Chris was in the
sixth week mm-hmm okay
and I think we had the spark in the few
minutes that we saw each other on group
dates but that was when it was like oh
like we like each other yeah but it was
late and I think that's why I had like a
one-on-one immediately after that too
because it was like okay I felt
something like you felt something but
you know okay well who do you see going
to hometowns Garrett Jason I'm torn
between I'm torn between Blake and
Colton because I think she's super into
Colton yeah I'm gonna go
Colten and wills okay okay do you think
Colton is there for the right reasons we
were talking about the Tia thing earlier
I don't know I've seen some spoilers for
Paradise that I don't know okay yeah
we've seen some Twitter drama we've seen
our my producers were in week six thank
you we don't even know what the series
we're on at this point there's so much
bachelor all year long um you know the
thing is I like Becca this Becca and
Becca ku friends so much I think she's
just like a really good person and she's
so sweet and you know we want the best
for her but I overall so so far I don't
know the guys are not nobody in
particular is like blowing me away I
have yes
I'm the same way no there's no like
dynamic character yeah there's no
dynamic one person on there that I'm
just like wow yeah he's got it like
they've got it
but there are people that I'm like this
she definitely has committed more
chemistry with him than she does with
the others but I like Becca to and she's
I like how she handles things like she's
very calm but she I feel like she's
strong and knowing what she wants which
I like but she is very like this mm-hmm
yeah she was really affected though by
like the guys drama on the past couple
of episodes like laughs yeah she said
you know I can't talk to you right now
Garrett so I don't know it's like on the
one hand we need the drama on the other
hand it's affecting her I do wonder if
the editing is messing with us so that
we don't know maybe what strong of a
connection she has with somebody because
it's not all you know it's always not
always easy when you know that's so
clearly the front-runner but I am really
wanting to dig in with the guys more at
this point like I'm hoping traveling
will really show us their personalities
more because I don't feel like I'm
getting to know their personalities
super well at this point I don't think
they're nice everybody's nice all right
we're gonna dig in
okay cool well Becca Tilly so dating
right now nothing too serious I know
you're so busy with all of your travel
and then of course scrubbing in with
Becca Tilly yes
having doing that podcast people are
obsessed so fun and Tanya who Tanya rad
who's my one of my probably my best
friend she is my co-host on it and so
it's now scrubbing in with Becca Tilly
and Tanya rad I've got the change and
it's just really I mean we have the best
time what are your favorite things to
talk about when you're doing it like
what really like well Tanya's dating
life is like one of the funniest things
ever and we approach dating so
differently like I'm very calm and try
to play it cool and I'm a little more
like hard to get and she just puts it
all out there and so hearing her how she
approaches like shy DM him like all
these questions that I think a lot of
girls who listen to our podcasts are
having the same dating problems or
questions and so um that's been that's
like a really fun dynamic it's a lot to
deal with I mean all of the platforms
all of the apps everything for me and
it's funny because I feel like you guys
are in this world where obviously people
know you from the show and like major
celebrities watch you from the show
leave living in LA I wanted to ask you
because Danielle Lombard was here and
she revealed that Justin Bieber had slid
into her DMS at one point a little bit
so have any celebrities slid into the
DMS Becca Julie anything I'm not sure I
believe you know I would share that are
you kidding yeah like yes I did hear
from Brad Pitt yeah other than that one
time he's married that was a bad example
one of it one of those one of those
Australians okay well listen to
scrubbing in with Becca Tilly and Tonya
rad you guys of course we are here live
every Tuesday morning recapping in the
Bachelorette and you can check out a new
episode of roses and Rose a over on our
YouTube channel will be up today we
always want to know what you guys think
of the show
reach out to us slide into our do this
we're giving you the option and thank
you so much for being here thanks for
having me have a great day guys
[Music]
you